that transition is happening almost a
year since virtual learning began and
because of the covid pandemic the
average child
is reading six months behind where they
should be
but a relatively new program available
to parents across the country is pairing
up reading coaches with kids
to try to get them back on track kirsten
joyce in studio
she's got the details brian the program
called just right reader was started a
year and a half ago
by harvard grad and founder sarah rich
i'm a reading expert i was a principal
for over 15 years and i kept turning
schools and helping kids in other
schools learn to read
and i realized that my own daughter was
having a hard time learning how to read
so
one day i brought home books that were
right at her level from school
and realized that just like if my own
kid was having a really hard time moms
across america and families across
america needed some help too
so she first started the program by
pairing kids up with age-appropriate
books as you heard but when the pandemic
hit she started hiring amazing teachers
to virtually read with the kids
and it's become as you can guess very
popular the reading and writing program
is for pre-k to sixth grade
they're paired up once or twice a week
for up to 30 minutes with a reading
coach there are also group sessions
available
we also have families that are joining a
reading class
because there's something really special
about being in a group of other kids
we never go higher than five kids or six
kids in a class because we really want
that intimate feeling
of kids being able to talk being able to
be heard
and being able to get the instruction
that's just right for them
there are about 100 people teaching
reading right now but sarah hires about
six to ten new teachers a week due to
the demand
and of course the pricing of the program
varies depending if you go once or twice
a week it is a monthly fee